ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap
ap à nos campagnes ne peux pas vous
parler
ap ap ap ap ap ap ap à revoir
sabrina veut aller vite dans les voir
puisqu'il a gagné mais il ya un monstre
qui est passée la regarder en soit être
un monstre vraiment horrible pour
laisser des traces pareil c'est affreux
il doit avoir des gros yeux rouges
mais les dents pointues et des écailles
sur le dos il est vrai que je n'ai
jamais vu de traces pareil faut pas
s'affoler
voyons 2
non ce ne sont pas des traces de pieds
mais cette forme me rappelle quelque
chose c'est affreux france pas j'étais
j'ai très peur je ne peux pas rester là
il faut que je retrouve pas l'endroit
pour me cacher la vérité c'est original
de toit calme d'habitude fils et de sa
fille je n'ai rien aux nombreux parents
compris ceux ci n'étaient pas restées là
qu'est ce qu'elle écrit sur le dollar
montre fraîche peinture fraîche alors là
on a un petit problème
tout à l'heure on arrivait qu est-ce qu
on trouve des pins des traces de pain
énorme là à ton avis efficace que ces
passants marchent soldats qui va marcher
sur le ponton quelqu'un et ça serait
peut-être attendez attendez attendez on
va continuer les enquêtes dit non
quasiment terminée tout à l'heure tu
dois être un petit peu marcher c'est
l'odeur pourquoi et tu n'as pas ta
remarque est sa nouvelle peinture
en fait selon reptiles si la même
couleur que les traces de pas le monstre
à de s'allonger sur le banc encore une
fois encore une fois casimir du calme
que remarquable carte quel point car
dans fin de vos doigts sur le banc
qu'est ce qu'elle écrit peinture fraîche
peinture fraîche
maintenant on regarde ton pied oui
comment trouve t il est vraiment très
jolie très jeune
non mais c'est parce que je te demande
quelle forme et il est bien il accroît
trois orteils et puis un mignon petit
allons maintenant avant soit un petit
peu mais ton pied sur la marque la
descend alors c'est fait curieux c'est
la même forme assez bizarre qu'un centre
est maintenant tout à l'heure en
arrivant j'ai marché sur le banc ton
pied s'est recouvert de peinture verte
ensuite et bien dur à recouvrir le sol
mais alors il n'y a pas de monstres et
non les magazines mais tu la trouves
toujours si horrible cette passe de pas
je la trouve plutôt mignonne mignonne
10e casimir
c'est peut-être pas le terme exact enfin
casimir tu t'es fait peur à toi même ce
n'est pas parce que quelqu'un a de
grands cris ou un nez crochu qu'il est
méchant
il ne faut pas convié les jeunes ah oui
ces mecs sapina c'est vrai écoute je
n'aurai plus jamais peur aussi bêtement
c'est robin qui se passe encore mais
qu'est ce que c'est une finale et boire
venez voir qu'est ce qu'il ya cette fois
il ya un monstre mais après voyons
casimir tu n'as pas honte
cette fois ci tu as eu peur de ton image